Thanks Gregg. So finally your on two and a half to three years old children
begin the third phase of language development which is the sentence phase. Here
they begin speaking in grammatical sentences. Now we know that children go
through predictable stages of language acquisition. That's from cooing to
babbling then onto one word utterances. Then two-word utterances. And finally,
into the sentence phase. Now, all of this happens in approximately the first
three years of life. It's no coincidence that the brain of a three year-old
child is about 80% of an adult size brain. Again, this demonstrates the
importance of the size of our brain and our ability to develop and understand
language.